team of 90 personnel and 20 cadaver dogs
have been searching through the wreckage
of Lahaina and they have made some
progress at the weekend just three
percent of the Town had been searched
now the figure is 25 percent the problem
has been identifying the human ashes
Left Behind over a thousand people
remain unaccounted for we actually have
three positive identifications from
fingerprints
three so I don't have more than three so
there's 96 that we don't have
fingerprints
so we can keep going deep like you
understand you know so just I'm trying
to be as reverent as I can but once we
get it positive we have to contact the
family
the process of informing relatives of
those identified will begin on Tuesday
residents of Lahaina they're expressing
their frustration at not being allowed
to return to assess the damage
themselves our Temple is um you know
is a historical site and we do have some
things that I saw that are made out of
metal and stone that are still remaining
and I just want to make sure that we are
able to secure those things and we've
already dealt with so much heartache
it's just like it has to deal with more
heartache on top of that it's just you
know I would like to be able to like
secure it like the things that are left
but it's because authorities believe
that human remains are distributed
widely throughout the rubble access
remains restricted they have to be very
careful very careful not to disrupt any
of the homes there so for those people
who have walked into Lahaina because
they really want to see
know that they are very likely walking
on Eevee
as the chief of police said the other
day that's why we're being so careful
the Maui police chief says he's hopeful
that 85 to 95 percent of the some 2200
damage structures in Lahaina will have
been searched by the weekend although he
says that timeline May slip the messages
remained consistent from authorities
over the last several days expect the
death toll to rise Shabbat hansi Al
Jazeera mahina Maui
foreign